bonjour tout le monde je suis redescendu ça signifiait
pour sortira en 2020 en France
je suis sur que vous allez adorer merci
symbolise hotel ou le terme marche a
travers vehicule pompier femme
enfants sundar hollande annee
joseph loyal la femme mets ta jeune
chambre
[Musique]
ironie -
ha c'était une tradition pour Java L'Amérique est
le pays le plus grand et le plus puissant
de la Terre
qui a compris
qu'eivin est au sommet
Janet ce ton Chinois vient manger ce qui
s'est passé Kendall je viens tu vois nous avons
la nouvelle page avec un non-  règles frites jusqu'à ce que
vous tombiez vous êtes venu vous battre avec le
mauvais
les phénix
donc votre professeur
je goûte la nourriture chinoise comme un
homme de gym ouais quelque chose comme ça
vous